everybody welcome to the stream I was
going to actually do a stream about a
different topic which is that it
actually now does seem that the molar
probe is getting close to wrapping up
but then we had this just stunning
breaking news of an election being a new
election being ordered in North Carolina
we've been following the alleged I use
the term voter fraud for a particular
reason but really it's election fraud by
Republicans in North Carolina we've been
following that basically since the day
after the midterm election in November
of 2018
and it has gotten so bad and undeniable
and corrupt that now a new election has
been ordered and we indeed may get one
so I'm going to get right into a New
York Times article about this we will go
over the details of this live stream and
the plan and everything momentarily but
I want to get right into the details
here new election ordered in North
Carolina race at center of fraud inquiry
this is the Republican candidate I'm
going to back this up and maybe we can
even listen to this together let's take
a look here audio audio is double it see
if we can actually listen to this
neither I nor any of the leadership of
my campaign were aware of or condoned
the improper activities that have been
testified to in this hearing through the
testimony I've listened to over the past
three days I believe in new election
should be called it's become clear to me
that the public's confidence in the
minds of district C general election
when even the Republican says it seems
as though there was election fraud that
helped the Republican you know that it's
serious let's get up to speed on the
story and I think just going through
this article will allow me to sort of
fill in the details North Carolina's
election authorities ordered a new
contest in the state's ninth district
after the Republican candidate
confronted by days of evidence that his
campaign under wrote an illegal
get-out-the-vote effort abandoned his
defense and called for a new vote the
question of whether Harris knew about
this is an open question and we may
never actually know more than likely
there will be some kind of
deal made where it will simply never be
pursued whether Harris actually knew or
didn't know and we know that proving
people's state of mind and what they
knew at the time sort of written
evidence of some kind text messages
email something seen any very hard to
prove that he knew but he recognizes the
seriousness of seriousness of this by
saying we need a new election the
unanimous ruling by the North Carolina
State Board of Elections was a startling
and for Republicans embarrassing turn in
a case of political chicanery that
convulsed North Carolina let's see if
they actually get into the details here
this is interesting Harris's
announcement represented a collapse of
the effort to stave off the new vote
which includes part of Charlotte and
runs through much of southeastern North
Carolina but the evangelical pastors
political surrender came only after a
damaging 24 hours for Harris and his
allies before he called for a new
election he acknowledged some of his
earlier testimony had been incorrect so
let me just explain to you basically the
the gist of what went on here this
individual named McCray Dallas jr. is a
campaign contractor and it's someone
we've spoken about many times
Dallas junior workers of Dallas jr. and
were are alleged or have been alleged to
have been participating in a scheme
whereby they went around collecting and
in some cases filling out absentee
ballots themselves now the way an
absentee ballot works is you mail it in
right nope nobody comes and picks it up
you certainly don't hand it to them in
an unsealed envelope as some voters were
directed to do so our best assessment
right now of how this worked is that
individuals claiming to be election
officials strategically went to homes
believed to be more likely Democratic
voters than Republican voters they
collected absentee ballots we have some
instances where absentee ballots were
submitted with a Republican vote on them
signed off on by a very narrow group of
individuals associated with this
operative McCray Dallas jr. in other
cases we believe again ballots that were
already filled out for the Democratic
candidate were simply never turned in
and it is you could sort of say it's
brilliant but at the same time it's not
in the sense that it failed at least it
appears as though it's going to fail and
there will be a new election and this
gets to you know so many different
issues relate to this number one
Republicans claim we need voter ID
because of voter fraud of course voter
fraud meaning individual voters
committing fraud in which can include
voting as a dead person for someone who
is dead but is on the voter rolls voting
in multiple locations all sorts of other
stuff that barely happens and in
instances where Republicans have tried
to prove a point by doing it they've
been caught and many of them have been
punished and sent to jail in prison
the real fraud is election fraud an
election fraud can include a number of
different mechanisms tactics and
techniques it can include bogus robo
calls telling people the elections on a
different day having people either by
mail in person before the election or on
the day of the election circulating
providing false information and
disproportionately democratic polling
places for example about what IDs are
required even though you don't actually
need the IDS or documents that you're
being told are actually necessary to
vote lobbying for the reduction of
polling places in disproportionately
democratic areas or disproportionately
non-white areas or disproportionately
poor areas all of these different things
are not voter fraud strictly speaking
they are election fraud they are voter
suppression and that's actually where
our efforts should be focused because
that's actually where the problem is and
this is a front and center case and the
best possible scenario here will be the
ordered new election happens it
takes place and the Republican loses
right I mean that's the scenario that
would be it would be extraordinarily
disappointing if after all of this a new
election is held and the Republican just
wins again and that's why if indeed
there is a new election we all need to
activate around making sure that
everybody votes in North Carolina in the
ninth district that certainly that no
election fraud takes place again and we
make sure that we can add one more on to
the swing in favor of Democrats that
took place in November of 2018 in the
midterm elections the last thing we need
is to go through all of this and to have
the Republican win again it would be
absolutely and totally disgusting and
we're gonna continue getting into the
details here about what criminal charges
may be brought and much more let me just
welcome everybody if this is your first
live stream usually I do this like at
the very top of the stream but nobody's
on the stream at that point so I'll do
it now this is a live stream and it's
different than our other videos in that
it's live which means you can
communicate with me the best way to get
your questions answered and your
comments read during the stream and I
can actually put them up on the screen
is to use the super chat function that's
the dollar sign the dollar symbol below
the chat window okay I will start
answering questions and comments it can
be about the North Carolina election
fraud story or anything else I will
start answering those momentarily I am
willing to open up the phone lines we
have been getting a very interesting
phone calls during the live streams
recently maybe it's something about
doing it in the evening that brings out
the brings out the trolls and the haters
but we've actually had some good
conversations as well I will open up the
phone lines during the stream if we get
10 new members patrons or YouTube
channel members during the stream we've
we've done this sometimes as quickly as
five minutes into the stream and
sometimes it has happened five minutes
before the end of the stream so if
people want me to take calls I'm glad to
do it but you can sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership
was my birthday February 2nd and in
honor of that we have a coupon code save
35 which will save you $35 off of the
$60 membership so choose the $60
membership on our website input the
coupon code save 35 you only pay 25
bucks that's two dollars and eight cents
a month if we get 10 of those I will
open up the phone lines and I am looking
forward to hearing from people
please don't troll the live chat ok I
make an effort to sort of monitor it and
we do have moderators deputize to make
decisions about what is and isn't
allowed but come on just don't don't
troll the live chat it's really it's
it's it's mostly sad that people spend
time trolling live streams on YouTube
and lastly also counting towards our
target of 10 new subscribers you can use
the join button right below this video
window and that will sign you up for a
YouTube membership ok let's continue
with our New York Times article about
what's going on in North Carolina mr.
Dallas this political operative refused
to testify before the board has not been
charged with any crimes in connection
with the 2018 election nor have any of
his workers who were often friends or
relatives with little ideological
interest in politics prosecutors are
examining the operation and are
considering whether to bring any
criminal cases these are crimes if if
this took place to the satisfaction of
the Election Board that they need to
have a new election that means crimes
were committed and I know that just
because a crime was committed
colloquially speaking doesn't mean that
it can be proven definitively in a court
of law
but in the same way that examples need
to be made out of the few people who
commit in person voter fraud examples
really need to be made about people who
are committing election fraud
particularly particularly when this is
not just a crime this is an attack on
one of the most important institutions
of democracy around which our entire
country's governmental systems are built
I am almost struggling for the words
here because this is this is of such
importance
we can't successfully send the message
legally speaking I'm talking about
criminal charges that is it's not just
oh you know what we figured out that you
robbed the election with these voter
suppression and election fraud
techniques but we're gonna have a new
election and everybody else gets away
scot-free no it can't be that way it has
to be that there are consequences and
that everybody is a prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law so if we don't
get criminal charges here it will be
extraordinarily disgusting the North
Carolina Board's decision will leave the
9th district in a state of protracted
limbo already the site of the final
unsettled house race of last year
midterm last year's midterm the district
is now poised to remain without
representation in Congress for at least
several more months it was not clear
whether mr. Harris who had a 905 vote
lead over his Democratic rival Dan
McReady in last year's election would
choose to run in the new election that
is actually an amazing element of this
the assumption is that the new election
means it's Harris versus McCready and
that's it it appears as though and I'm
this is just happening now it appears as
though when the new election is called
for it's considered a special election
meaning that people who want to run can
run and it is not guaranteed it's not
automatic that Harris is again in the
race and we have to assume I mean I hope
that at this point if McCready is in
this new election that has been called
for and Harris is not and Republicans
find some clown I would hope that that
irreparable damages the Republican side
and that McCready simply wins cleanly
and overwhelmingly but that that is an
interesting question will Harris were
even run or will he feel I don't know
maybe the shame of how tainted this
entire process was in favor of him on
his behalf and not run at all which
would be absolutely and and endlessly
fascinating we just won't know we're not
going
you know that for some time but just
undeniable and you know we this isn't
like a pat ourselves on the back thing
because I and many others on the Left
were covering but North Carolina nine
from the beginning this is merely a
message that if we actually pay enough
attention to this stuff well if we pay
enough attention ideally this stuff
wouldn't happen in the first place
but if we identify something like this
and pay enough attention to it and
continue pushing it if the facts are on
our side and if there is not this sort
of force majeure invoked from from the
elites and and those in control of a lot
of these systems we can actually make
things happen we can actually make
things happen and now the full
completion of this coming full circle
would be taking yet another seat in what
remember maybe not as exciting as we
would have wanted the November midterms
to be in terms of their results still
historically huge gains for Democrats in
the House of Representatives and now the
potential to add one more so massive
massive story and I want to hear what's
on your mind about it so let's go and
check out super chats and messages that
are coming in once again
I if people want to call in I'm willing
to open up the phone lines but every
time we do that it costs us money so we
usually set some kind of new member
challenge if we get 10 new members
during the stream I will open the phone
lines and take phone calls for a while
we have one new member so far and that's
Anthony Brown Anthony Brown has taken
advantage of the fact that it was my
birthday a couple of weeks ago and has
used the birthday coupon code SAVE 35
has gotten a $60 membership for just 25
bucks that's for the entire year you can
keep that for as long as you want that's
how the program is funded that's what
funds the streams and the phone line and
all of the stuff so we're one out of ten
I'll open up the phone lines if we get
to ten let's do it david pakman.com
slash membership it's a very very
reasonable number I must say okay negan
the cliffhanger sent a dollar
ninety-nine Super chat saying wheat come
back here and give mommy a kiss
Reeth I don't understand the reference
but if that's worth a dollar ninety-nine
to have me say then I guess everybody
got what they wanted out of that Jackson
with a $5 super chat womp womp classic
projection yeah we we've been talking
about the projection that exists on the
right with this issue of voter ID and
voter fraud and voter suppression and
voter and election fraud to call it what
it actually is four years and the the
big picture of the projection that takes
place is Republicans claim in order to
ensure the integrity of Elections
we need voter ID we need to cut voting
hours we need to cut voting early voting
we need to reduce the number of polling
places we've got to do all these things
because of in-person voter fraud and of
course in-person of voter fraud barely
exists the Brennan Center for Justice
has studied this extensively over some
billion and a half votes across who
knows how many elections there were you
know and few enough of these in-person
voter fraud examples that you could
probably count them on ten fingers
roughly but the real fraud the real
disenfranchisement are the tactics they
claim to want as solutions to voter
fraud which doesn't exist and the type
of election fraud that we saw in North
Carolina's not a district and it's a
beautiful thing that we are finally now
hopefully getting some justice on that
issue
Eddie xkey with a dollar ninety-nine
superjet says would you be press
secretary for Bernie Sanders white house
uh I mean I guess I don't think there's
any risk to anybody this is sort of like
would you rather eat three avocados or
not be allowed to eat chocolate for ten
years I mean it's unlikely that this is
ever a decision I'm gonna have to make
so I don't I don't know I I would I
would be Bernie's press secretary if you
wanted me to be Dark Knight says have
you read mutual aid by crop Atkin
Kropotkin I have not I don't know what
it is but it sounds it sounds
interesting let's see maybe
I will look it up mutual aid Potkin
let's see what this is mutual aid a
factor of evolution is a 1902 essay
collection by russian naturalist and
anarchist philosopher peter kropotkin
the essays initially published in the
English periodical the 19th century
explore the role of mutually beneficial
cooperation and reciprocity or mutual
aid in the animal kingdom and human
societies both past and present it's an
argument against theories of social
Darwinism that emphasize competition and
survival of the fittest and against the
romantic depictions of writers such as
jean-jacques Rousseau sounds interesting
sounds interesting I will I'll add it to
my list and see see if it is something
that I read soon I've got a lot of stuff
on that list I will admit okay
Victor Jackson sends a five-dollar super
chat I'm a progressive interested in
Andrew Yang's universal basic income it
would translate to six dollars an hour
for a 40-hour week should the new
minimum wage be nine to ten dollars an
hour to help small businesses with ubi
I'm not sure I understand what what you
mean should the new minimum wage be nine
to ten dollars to help small businesses
with universal basic income I'm not sure
I know what you mean and I apologize in
a lot of states the minimum wage is
beyond that already and if if we're
thinking about the thousand dollars a
month that Andrew yang is proposing does
it work out to that to six dollars an
hour for a 40-hour week that's like 240
a week four point three weeks per month
it's about a thousand dollars yeah I
don't really understand the exact
context but I think that you know I've
expressed support for ubi I've also
expressed openness for a negative into
income tax arrangement and I think the
minimum wage should be higher but I
don't know that I totally understand
exactly as you're asking it at rent land
were Trent land were with a $5 super
chat how do we push to lower the age
restrictions for president or vice
president I would love to see a Oh see
as VP for Bernie and
2020 hashtag Burnie 2020 you know I I
don't for me I've identified what I
think are the biggest issues in politics
right now and meta issues so to speak
and those would be campaign finance and
how elections are financed climate media
consolidation and net neutrality because
those impact how we learn about every
single issue that that that exists in
the world ranked choice voting I have
stated is a really important thing but
for me allowing young even younger
people than 35 to become president or VP
it's not because I just turned 35 I
can't run either way I wasn't born in
the US it's not a high priority for me
right now and right now I actually I
wouldn't want to see a OC as Bernie's VP
I think she's too inexperienced and too
naive on a lot of issues and I think
it's great that she's in the house but
she is not something that seems to me
like it would be a priority okay mark
canning has signed up by using the join
button below the video window he is a
new YouTube member and that is number
two for the evening we're looking for 10
and then I'll open up the phone lines
art Flores says if you were president
would you pardon Edward Snowden that's a
complicated question because he's not
even been charged so you you I guess
you're saying what is you like a
pre-emptive pardon to make prosecution
irrelevance I don't know it's not clear
to me that I would but I I wouldn't rule
it out but I can't be President because
I wasn't born in the u.s. Steven Smith
is a new YouTube member that's number 3
for the evening Carlos Santana great
guitarist is a new YouTube member for
Theo H is number 5 Jackson is number 6
so we are 60% of the way to me opening
up the phone lines happening happening
quickly this evening
surprising in a way Dark Knight has sent
the $9 99 cent super chat you've made me
so happy thank you
you're welcome I don't know what I did
but I appreciate it getting with a $10
super chat love your program about time
we're going to get a new election and do
you think 45 will get impeached
I don't think 45 will get impeached I
think we need to completely put out of
our minds the idea that Donald Trump is
going to be impeached and removed by the
Senate or resign it could happen but I
think that the path forward it's already
February of 2019 that process if it
started today even if it were to succeed
in removing the president could extend
beyond the November 20 2011 by voting I
think that that's what we should be
focusing on coh says changing the
subject what do you think about treating
guns like cars bolt-action or similar
equals a SI license semi-auto mag
federal a license increasing training
required for each yang Bernie Warren
okay so I think that there is a lot to
be learned from regulating firearms like
cars
what about requiring insurance for
firearms I think it's just a no-brainer
there's there's no question about it
what about requiring periodic
relicensing I think that that should be
done what about making the process for
getting the firearm more strict like
what is required in many states to get a
driver's license so yes I think that a
lot of what you're saying makes sense
Theo as far as different classes in the
way you're describing I'm open to that
but I don't know that I'm in a position
to say specifically what they would be
offhand black wave 54 says you're happy
late birthday blood oh geez got to keep
the block on lock know what I'm saying
keep it moving P gang gang squad right
yeah I mean this is that's extreme
actually but I'm glad that you reminded
me that I forgot to make that
designation okay so we are 60% of the
way to me opening up the phone lines
today if you want me to open up the
phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we are
inviting you to become a member at david
pakman.com slash membership it's a very
modest
target of ten new members and were six
out of ten they're already the normal
rates for membership which funds the
show I think are very reasonable six
dollars a month or sixty for the year
but because I turned 35 on February 2nd
and I wanted to do something 35 related
to drown my sorrows not Soros but my
Soros did I say that right I feel like I
never say that word correctly sorrows my
sorrows that makes I think that's I was
saying it wrong there
listen English is my second language
give me a break what I did was I created
a coupon code which is saved 35 and if
you apply that code to the $60 a year
membership it drops a membership to only
25 bucks if you can afford 25 dollars a
year and you don't think that the david
pakman show is worth it all of the hours
and hours and hours of content that we
put out please leave right now but if
you can't afford it then don't worry
about it because the whole point here is
the show is for everybody and we depend
on the support of the few to provide the
show to the many but sign up were six
tenths of the way there and I would love
to open up the phone lines and hear from
some people a Derek Busby says what sort
of news stories have been crowded out by
mainstream media lately that you feel
should have been covered there's a lot
of state-level
legislation that is passing that is
important now it's only in one state but
there are some themes that we are seeing
in terms of some of the conservative and
right-wing stuff that is being done at
the state level which because of
everything going on federally is not
getting the attention it deserves and
I'm gonna make an effort to start
covering some of those Derek even though
this is mostly a national program
because our audience is all over the
country and the world I'm gonna make an
effort to start covering some of those
stories if things just even mildly
settle down with what's going on
federally victor jackson says i mean
instead of a $15 an hour minimum wage oh
instead of 15 an hour minimum wage
should it be ubi plus $10 an hour here's
the problem with that I don't like the
idea of justifying
lower wages on the basis of the
government providing a sort of bailout
for me the the appeal of a universal
basic income is not that it should make
it easier for corporations to pay people
less it's that it should raise the floor
and give folks at least some basic level
of subsistence with which they can maybe
have more options in terms of the jobs
they accept because they have that
$12,000 a year
anything that is any the idea of
justifying lower wages from employers on
the basis of a government subsidy I
don't like and that's why I have a huge
problem with what goes on with wal-mart
and McDonald's and and a lot of those
companies Jackson says Jesse Lee
Peterson says you aren't a man if you
aren't a conservative does that mean he
believes gender isn't determined by DNA
but by societal factors whom is JLP
pro-trans amazing I have this idea
actually should I say this I probably
shouldn't let me let me be more vague
about it I'm working with someone right
now about recreating on recreating my
last appearance on Jesse Lee Peterson's
program in person in Los Angeles when I
was out at politican we're working on
ways to make that happen again
but on a bigger scale let me just put it
that way okay well I won't say more at
this point because I think that there
are people involved in discussions that
I shouldn't preempt Kris Van in Wigan
says if you read this Crito sorry Kris
Vee is fine
Kris V I appreciate the attention paid
to objectivity found you through Anton a
sceptical human keep it up Thank You
Kris I appreciate that
Roy early says I think Pakistan is not a
reliable ally given their blind eye to
terrorists do you agree with Trump
cutting aid to it until they change
behavior I have no problem with reducing
or cutting aid to countries in order to
try to drive compliance with what we
want we're not we're not mandated to
give aid I have no problem with that the
problem I have anytime Trump does
something like saying we're going to cut
aid until they change their behavior is
number one Donald Trump doesn't even
really understand what their behavior is
number two it's not clear that Donald
Trump even has a good assessment of what
their behavior should be and number
three because of this sort of ADHD
nature of this administration I wouldn't
be comfortable with the idea that if the
behavior changes we would actually give
the aide back so conceptually I'm fine
with it
in terms of execution the last people I
want doing stuff like that is the Trump
administration okay Oh mate Oh Mendoza
with the dollar nine and superjet says
three six nine three six nine all right
I don't know what that means hopefully
that doesn't appear in some kind of
white supremacists compilation because I
just said something I don't even
understand
Shane babka always love seeing Shane
babka because babka is one of my
favorite desserts chocolate babka and
pistachio baklava nothing more delicious
than a chocolate babka since Trump is
such a sore loser do you think he'll
have a hissy fit that could put the
country in danger if he loses in 2020
yes and I've been talking about that for
a while that's a real risk and we have
to assume that the institutions of power
will prevent that from happening
Greg Madsen says do you take questions
from members to ask your guests I have a
couple of longest questions too long for
here that I'd like Andrew yang to answer
yep send it in I I would love to I am
looking forward to having Andrew back on
and I questioned ideas are always
appreciated
Oscar edge or eggy egg a with a fifty a
Swedish kronor super chat says economist
from Sweden here Oh awesome keep up the
good work by the way you know more about
our tax system the most of our local
pundits hey you know what's interesting
Oscar the other day I mentioned that
someone called in and said hey David if
Sweden does so well with no minimum wage
why do we need one in the United States
I researched it and what I found was
Sweden does not have a minimum wage
particularly because labor unions are so
strong that it's not been an issue where
there have been problems of wages being
too low like in other words they have
they have other ways to keep wages
higher and a Swedish
Rodan and said david that's not true we
have a minimum wage and I researched it
again wondering if I said something
wrong and what I found was no Sweden
doesn't have a minimum wage so did I
mess up there I don't know I thought
that I was saying the right thing Hey
Jude says can't spell hatred without Red
Hat love the show David thank you
appreciate it
Hasan jf thoughts on Andrew yang stance
against free college didn't know that
was his position I think that may have
been a more recent thing I will look
into that ray 1708 says saludos David
sending us to you great to see you in
the chat okay let me thank a few people
who have signed up for membership a lot
of new members here let's see we have
Anthony ha who is the seventh new member
of the evening Dion West number 8 Thank
You Diane Douglas sax number 9
Gerard Carey number 10 and Michael Ryan
number 11 we have made it to 10 new
members during the livestream so as
promised I am going to open up the phone
lines a little bit at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
you can go ahead and call in now if you
would like I'm gonna read a couple other
super chats and then we will go to the
phone lines once again the phone number
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 52 talk to me keep
signing up keep sending super chats the
progressive voice has arrived have you
do you listen to nos have you listened
to NAS favorite album or songs of his
the only NAS song I know is if I rule
the world if you rule the world I forget
the name of it I listen to it when I was
like 12 and beyond that I'm not super
familiar with nas's work but I have no
problem with him for sure you know he
seems like a nice guy for sure
James Buki Nobu Chino says what do you
say to the progressive Bernie voters who
voted for Trump over Hillary last an
election and might do so again if it's
Kamala Harris I tell them that they're
messing up the country and not to do it
and that it's toxic and
please please stop game fire 74 I'm a
constituent in North Carolina's ninth
district and I'm pissed
also worked on McCready's campaign so
now we get a new election here how about
a new 2016 presidential election would
not hold my breath for that my friend
would not hold my breath for that Theo
says could you put the number on the
screen um I probably could but I can't
now because if I start if I type numbers
crazy crazy things start happening on
the screen and it's bad for everybody
like for example I might accidentally
put people's phone numbers on the screen
which I accidentally did last time and
it was it was really bad when I did that
people started getting text messages so
for the next time I think I'll be able
to do it okay I'll mention the number
once more and then I'm gonna go to the
phone's 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let me see if
I can get there's a certain certain
stuff I need here in order to be able to
take calls all right and a lot of people
are stacking up on the phone lines let's
see what's going on with our first
caller of the evening from the 7 8 1
area code caller from 7 8 one who's this
where are you calling from yo David how
you doing it's will hey will what's
going on I called last week and I had
the blast doing it so now I'm gonna give
it another shot
sorry you did last week I'm having a
hard time hearing you I call last week
okay didn't hear me now I just moved
into a better spot yes I got ok ah how
many political questions for you tonight
but you do were you ban will your kid
did you call last week with a terrible
connection I I called last week from the
same spot and my connection was
completely fine okay all right well it
could be a conspiracy yeah maybe I'll
try to stand next to the window please
hang out the window just to get a better
signal for us oh man it's getting worse
okay what's the quittin try to get the
question out at least
oh boy man will we're totally losing you
alright will next time I'm gonna make a
note on wills account here that he has a
bad signal just so I know up front
no I'm kidding about that will okay
let's try the five six two area code
caller from five six - who's there I
can't hear ya we can hear you fine who's
this hi this is Daniel hey Daniel hi I'm
so I had a question about Bernie Sanders
foreign policy where do you stand on him
when it comes to foreign policy well on
which issue particularly I'd say when it
comes to Saudi Arabia and how US Arabia
what's his position yeah so I from what
I understand Bernie Sanders has made
comments critical of Saudi Arabia and
he's pointed out that the relationship
is not a particularly moral one and that
we need to revisit this Alliance which
is a position I agree with great also
fall question do you think like that
would be a deciding factor when it comes
to a lot of the comparison between other
Democratic nominees foreign policy in
general and policy yeah it's important
for me yeah I mean so here's the thing
about foreign policy we have to balance
so if we live in the United States
domestic policy is going to affect us
much more directly and in the short run
foreign policy is going to direct affect
us less directly and over a longer term
and the term may be long enough that the
next person might actually change the
policy so for me foreign policy is less
about how is it going to directly affect
us while that individual is president
but more about what impact will it have
on our relationships with other
countries so that's where like for
example with Trump the disastrous impact
he's had on alliances is going to affect
us beyond his presidency more than for
example continuing to sell weapons to
Saudi Arabia which I'm against and every
recent president has done okay
all right was that right well yeah
that's it thank you appreciate the call
great to hear from you okay let me get
to a couple of super chats before we
stick with the phones let's see here
Jorge Luis 88 with a hundred Mexican
pesos super chat David if your parents
are from Argentina how come your last
name sounds British no my last name is
an Eastern European Jewish last name
that has been modified to some degree
and there are Jewish people in Argentina
so that's why the progressive voice asks
do I ever get angry yes when you make
negative videos about me Sahil Oscar
edge or eggy says you were correct no
minimum wage strong unions in Sweden
Jackson says progressive voice is the
TMZ of leftist YouTube I like that
description I would actually make that
the tagline the TMZ of left-wing YouTube
gr has reappeared
it's the DS yo the pack is the man with
the feet in the breeze though who is it
David DZ the Pac Man see me loved gr
yeah GRE you got to get that membership
renewed buddy we want you back
everybody's clamoring for you to be back
okay let's see who's holding we've got a
bunch of people holding let's go to our
caller from the 403 area code caller
from 403 who's this where you're calling
from
hey David can you hear me I can hear you
so well it's amazing okay great
yeah I'm calling from Canada and I've
been watching yourself for years and I
just think what you do is great
it kind of just nice to have like a
rational reinforcement to a lot of what
I'm already thinking thank you like my
question for you is I think that the
that Donald is actually a major threat
to Western democracy and I'm just
wondering if there's anything that
because on your show you constantly
mention for people to get out and vote
which totally makes sense I'm just
wondering what people outside of the US
can do because like I was wondering if
if there's anything like somebody like
myself can do to support Bernie Sanders
as a Canady
outside of the u.s. like anything that
we can do to help well listen there's a
couple different things going on one
you're not allowed to donate money if
you're outside the US two American
candidates that would be foreign foreign
financial contribution to an election
but for sure I wonder our Canadians
allowed to canvass and get out the vote
in the United States it's providing
something of value but maybe not value
in the sense that it would be banned
that's a question if you you know I
don't know if you live in in Toronto and
you want to come over and help in
Michigan is that legal
I don't know I would look into that
number one number two I think that you
know if you like Trump you don't really
give a [ __ ] what people in other
countries think about him in fact you
were probably emboldened if you hear
that our allies are sort of not pleased
with Trump because you rationalize it by
saying if they're upset Trump must be
doing really good stuff for us but I do
think that there are voters who are
influenced by the fact that they prefer
a president who is seen as who is
respected and seen as an important
figure around the world right now
Trump's not even invited to
conversations about climate change
Trump is increasingly not a factor in
important geopolitical negotiations so
the more that other countries can make
it clear to Americans that with
ex-president you're not taken seriously
maybe that would have some impact on
independent voters okay yeah that makes
sense like I kind of figured there's
nothing really that we could do legally
hmm here but you know anything we could
do to help because it's quite concerning
I would say I agree I agree well listen
the fact that you're presumably in your
country supporting progressive
candidates who then may work with Trump
and pull him to the left that's
something right I mean it's it's
something yeah definitely we have our
election here next year or so so we'll
see how that goes we will indeed yeah
all right thank you for the call really
appreciate it yeah thanks a lot David
cool okay before I go too
phones again let me first thank Raphael
Cabral gr is back as a member I
suggested he become a member again and
gr is back
Rafael Cabral Cabral Mike G Shane Barlow
new members a big big evening a historic
evening any historic evening as I like
to say for the David Pakman show a
couple of super chats here Bobby Lee
asks what are my all-time favorite
comedies TV and or movies okay for
movies I like the airplane movies The
Naked Gun movies and the Austin Powers
movies that's the style of comedy that I
like for movies favorite TV comedies I
would say Seinfeld and Curb Your
Enthusiasm no anti-semitism please and
what else do I like
I guess those I don't know Roy early
David would you ever debate that radio
host dennis prager at politican I have
many friends who are fooled by Prager
used deceptive arguments and videos yeah
I mean it would depend on the topic a
lot of topics like the religion topics
I'm not the right person to debate him
but depending on what the issue was like
if it's something more economic I would
I just don't know that that's his area
of expertise john Kuhlman says what will
happen to all of the workers insurance
workers and medical billing workers on
their Medicare for all a lot of them
will not be necessary and that's that's
any serious plan for Medicare for all
deals with that reality and that's a
good thing in the long run although
anytime you have a major shift to how
elements of society or organized jobs
can be lost but that is not in and of
itself a reason not to do it if it makes
sense okay
triple x-- euro babe
wants to know what the title of the
stream is then the title of the stream
is related to a new election being
ordered in North Carolina's ninth
district over Republican election fraud
and you can rewind it to see that the
needle drop Anthony Fantan Oh of the
needle drop frame of Fame who has
endlessly more subscribers than I do
isn't in the superjet he says thanks for
continuing to be one of the most
excellent and consists
that political voices on YouTube you're
the best
Thank You Anthony and I will then vote
venmo you back the 999 now like I
promised you can expect that right when
we're done with the stream I really
appreciate that
gr this membership is your face DZ love
gr it's great to have you back gr very
very much appreciate you back as a
member okay let's see we're taking calls
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I see one from
Wisconsin holding Quon I picked up on
you like two days ago so I'm not gonna
go to you just in case you don't want to
be hanging on just to be just with peace
and love to be upfront because I want to
give new people a shot let's go to the
505 area code who's calling from 505
today is that me that is you yeah hi
David I've been a viewer for a long time
I wanted to ask if you heard about that
intercept article that came out in like
2017 it was covered by Kyle kolinsky and
said something about the former CEO of
Blackwater or gonna say organizing a
kind of new intelligence agency funded
by billionaires and well so let's see
yeah Aran's so yeah I understand his
trajectory I don't know the article
you're talking about but he bait from
what I understand he rebranded so
Blackwater got such a bad name because
of everything they did while they were
called Blackwater
it was rebranded twice I think at one
point it was called it might have been Z
like is XE or something like that and
then I think it was pygar Swan at one
point maybe we might be thinking of two
different companies and then most
recently its Academy with an I on the
end instead of a why so I don't know
about it being a quote new company but I
think it's just been kind of like a
rehashing a rehabbing of the name and
they still do the exact same thing yeah
I was just wondering if they have like a
connection to Donald Trump via Betty
deboss and well yeah I mean listen so
err
prince was allegedly involved in trying
to negotiate or create a back-channel
between the Saudis I'm trying to believe
it was between the Saudis and Kushner
and Eric Prince I think was involved in
some meeting at the Seychelles which by
the way I hear is lovely at every time
of year I have a friend who just went
there I would love to go and that that's
what rings a bell so there's that
involvement as soon as Trump suggested
pulling out of Syria Eric Prince started
showing up on TV saying hey we should
pull out and let's hire contractors like
by the way his company to go in there
and do an endless an endless profitable
presence in Syria so yeah he's
definitely very wrapped up with Trump
yeah I was just wondering about if like
that intercept article is developed at
all cuz I haven't seen any yeah I don't
know the article specifically but you
know I it might be worth looking into I
don't know how accurate it is now okay
yeah there's probably newer about the
while as well since it's since it's been
a couple years alright thanks for the
call very much appreciate it let me say
okay so we have someone here having
trouble
xxx euro babe which is not yeah when I
started doing a political show I didn't
imagine I would be talking to xxx euro
babe at 7 p.m. on a Thursday but I am a
xxx euro babe says bro I thought it was
about the POTUS election oh my god yeah
no so if you came in here thinking a new
election has been called for the
presidency I would slap myself silly and
realized that's not happening FK n dumb
bastard says I can't join for some
reason please help David let me mention
something because this is it there's
such a common user error so whenever I
announce a coupon code and I say the
coupon code only works with a certain
membership people will try to apply it
to the wrong membership ok the coupon
code saved 35 saves you 35 dollars only
off of the $60 membership if you try to
apply the coupon code to the $6 a month
membership
you can't save $35 a year off of a $6 a
month membership so I'm seeing a lot of
messages from people saying coupon code
not working you
to switch to yearly and then hit sign up
and only off of the $60 a year
membership will the coupon code work so
if you're having that as an issue you
got to switch to 60 a year Gerry Hickel
says what's your opinion on William bard
Trump's new attorney general he's
obviously intelligent and seemed
reasonable in his confirmation hearings
my opinion is he's qualified to be
Attorney General but it's not clear that
he is going to allow the full scope of
the Moller probe to be the full results
of the Moller probe to be known publicly
and that's my concern about him
Gerry let's go to the nine one nine area
code who's calling from nine one nine
today hello yeah who's this um oh is
that um is that person who I'm the
Decker recipie who called for that oh
you're the doc a guy who called okay
yeah how are things going on it's pretty
good how about you
no I meant specifically with regard to
the daka stuff I'm not just shooting the
breeze with oh I'm sorry man oh nothing
nothing much changed right now so if I
wrote just to catch the audience up
you're 17 years old right yeah okay so
you called and do you want to say your
name or just give a name so that we can
just I can call you something
Oh my name is Uwe Lisi okay that's
that's perfect
you Lise he's called in saying he's 17
he's a daca recipient he's worried about
what happens when he turns 18 should he
go back to his home country or not from
what I researched for you Ulysses
nothing changes until you're 31 that
that's what I researched and I
encouraged you to get an attorney to
help you out with this I think there are
free attorneys available yes you every
said that and did you do it did you did
you look for an attorney um I couldn't
really cuz I was pretty busy with school
and had worked all right
I really had time cool well I would
definitely do it is what what other
family members are here in the u.s.
um with daca or just in general just you
know yeah in general you're not here
alone I'm guessing no no I have a vibe
cool
well yeah listen I mean I would
hopefully there will be some kind of for
all extension to status and ideally a
path to citizenship but in the mean time
I wouldn't do anything until I talk to
an attorney and look how can the
attorney help me with well the attorney
so we're like I think that turning 18
doesn't signify anything I think you're
okay until you're 31 but an attorney
would be able to tell you nothing
changes when you turn 18 or here's what
we should do because you're turning 18
you want to be super clear about that
you know yeah about today oh yeah I was
going to ask I just want to ask how
battle I'm Jesse Peters
oh yeah please you don't mind of course
um why so I was thinking that why why
does he always and win so I remember you
always be on his show yep and why so do
you think he's always done like I
doesn't think he just went to arguments
just because he's on a shovel if he's
like I'm indifferent I'm like different
like a Bentley political horn or a
different beer show you see what I
changed himself word he would be the
política know so he I didn't see it but
I heard from other people at politican
that he was the exact same Jesse Lee
Peterson I don't think he thinks he's
ever lost like I think he just thinks he
wins every every debate everything he
participates in that that's almost what
makes it interesting that he doesn't
ever believe you know what that was
really stupid I looked like an idiot
there he thinks he just does incredibly
well all the time and that's why it's
funny all right
Ulysses thank you for the call and keep
us posted about what's going on with the
daca status all right all right thank
you okay yep take care all right let's
see I've got a couple other super chats
here William Turner with the big super
chat for the evening 20 bucks would you
be interested in organizing a discussion
between stephanie kelton who's been on
the show and andrew yang who's been on
the show twice to talk about universal
basic income modern monetary theory and
a theory and a federal jobs program the
rift between their views would make for
a great sit down that would be awesome
and we're starting to explore whether
we're going to do the David Pakman show
live in person with a studio audience in
Boston
and if we could get Andrew yang and
stephanie kelton that would be
interesting but they'd have to travel I
don't know if our budget would allow for
it but I would be very interested in
making that discussion happen Shawn
Geiss says the media is acting like the
molar report could be the end of Trump
isn't it more likely to be the six other
investigations into him and the Russia
one can lead to other investigations yes
listen the most direct path to getting
Trump out now given that it's almost
March of 2019 is voting him out in 8
well in 20 months ok that's the most
direct path whatever else is possibly
going to happen is going to take at
least as long as getting to the next
election so let's consider it a possible
bonus but let's just vote Trump out
that's I think the best path forward and
I think you're completely right a DJ Al
Gore says can we get the Republicans to
flip on climate change if we convince
them that it will make their kids gay
what will make their climate change
would make their kids gay yeah they
probably would flip that that's that's
interesting that I like that idea
I'm kidding by the way Suton says I
heard Andrew yang doesn't support free
college because ubi seems more feasible
with lessening student loan burdens also
doesn't want people to think college is
the solution for everyone what are your
thoughts he's making good points and I
think what makes sense is it we're not
it doesn't have to be free college
period what we want to do is make state
universities and colleges tuition free
that I think is very different than just
saying free college all college for
everybody and I don't even know that
anyone's actually proposing that so it's
much more narrow than that triple x euro
babe says you can be against gay
marriage as a Christian and still vote
YES on the issue as to not impose on
others government shouldn't favor any
religion Jesus would vote for Bernie
triple x-- Packman triple x I mean you
really can't argue with that
you really can't okay let's pick up on
another phone call here since we have a
lot of people holding any phone numbers
I recognize not seeing too many let's
try
let's try the nine seven eight I think
nine seven eight might be might be
Boston who's calling from nine seven
eight today does that mean that is you
yeah I hate it I'm hey David I I've
actually called several times before
asin's just talking about just random
stuff and remind me your name is Freddie
Freddie okay and where are you calling
from Freddie um I'm calling from
Leominster actually from Leominster
alright Leominster is interesting mm-hmm
okay what's going on
here the court questions will actually
get to what I have written down here why
are the Republicans why are the
Republicans so against the idea of
climate change actually being a thing
well they're against it because they
believe well the it depends which ones
but there's a big class of Republicans
that is against accepting the reality of
climate change because in their minds it
necessitates a particular political
solution the truth is that merely
accepting the science doesn't tell us
for sure what the solution should be we
should still talk about what the
solution is they see it as mandating a
particular solution and it's a solution
that's not good both for the lifestyles
they want to live and for the business
interests that they are supported by
okay all right so what was the game you
did have written down okay what am i
written down is that to give you some
background clarification my parents have
a close friend who works very closely
with children with special needs for
roughly 25 years now and she has often
expressed how the school administration
from where she works at often mistreats
her students by I think the examples
that she gave is like restricting their
access to don't going on certain field
trips and not allowing them to go to or
like egg like eggs out of a fire way
fire exit in case of a emergency or such
and I'm guessing my question is how to
how how could she
or how could
how could you like address the
mistreatment of our children in you know
Freddy I I'm not sure I understand the
question
I like the spontaneous question way more
than the written one so let's go out on
a high note with that one and then we'll
pick it up on the next call how does
that sound all right cool all right glad
we agree on that Freddy always great to
hear from you Leominster very very
interesting place I've been there many
times let's go to the four to five area
code
caller from four to five who's this
hello my name is Derrick and I am in
Illinois all right how are you doing
today most callers are way way loud so
I'm just gonna turn you down to hear
I'm doing great what's what's on your
mind today hello I got a lot of things
see um maybe take the biosolids you know
I wrote down the media will frame this
primary season to the benefit of those
that support their interests their
corporate interest they will argue for
this interest as if they're in the
center how do we weave the narrative
that supports our interest well we have
to demand the type of media that we want
and we need to I hate to say it we need
to fund the type of media that we want
because you're completely right which is
that different corporate media channels
have made editorial decisions about how
they're going to frame politics and
elections MSNBC has taken a more
centrist Democratic Party perspective
Fox News is obviously in the loony bin
on the right cNN has taken a we are in
the middle but we are not afraid to hold
Trump accountable perspective but yet
CNN just announced yesterday or the day
before that they're hiring this
right-wing hack Sarah is go Flores to
run their entire 20/20 election coverage
so we know exactly what we can expect
there so we just need to be making
informed decisions as consumers both in
terms of what we fund and what we watch
and not allow we can't pretend as though
these aren't just corporate media
channels that are picking a flavor of
corporate media
that they calculate is the most
profitable and that's why by the way the
criticism that the Dutch historian that
triggered Tucker Carlson I don't know if
you've seen that but we've got a clip on
it up on the channel the criticism he
made that Tucker's a millionaire funded
by billionaires and he doesn't talk
about certain issues and nobody does you
could apply that to CNN or or to a
slightly lesser degree MSNBC as well
right they're paid not necessarily for
what they say but also for what they
don't pay as well absolutely absolutely
so we've got to make sure that everybody
is aware of that and not fall into this
trap you know CNN as liberal fake news
they lit they hired a literal Republican
bomb thrower to run their entire 20/20
coverage Derek thank you appreciate the
call I know you have a litany of
questions today but I've got a bunch of
other people to get to and limited time
let me mention a couple of other super
chats Roy Earle says am i aware that
Benjamin Netanyahu praised the 46
bombing of the King David hotel in
British Palestine no I had no idea but
I'm an anti Netanyahu guy so even if
even if that's the case I'm equally
against him and Sonja Guzman has sent a
five-dollar super chat Sonya great to
see you haven't seen you for a little
bit and Sharon Velez has signed up for a
new membership as well as Garrick Ho
Garrick and Sharon great to see you as
members okay let's try a caller from the
so many people to choose from I just
pick numbers that look good let's go to
the 205 area code I have no idea where
205 is what part of the country is 205
205 are you there oh I'm there yeah okay
David this is James and me 205 is the
area code for Alabama Oh America I was
offshore Mobile Alabama I didn't
actually put any feet on dry land so to
speak when I visited Pensacola and was
out on a boat and we got dangerously
close to the Alabama border but I didn't
actually make it oh lucky for you
in my question it is do you think that
the recent rise of the right on YouTube
will force the left to sort of have its
own sort of rise on YouTube well listen
I just saw I recently read a very good
analysis of the right left and middle on
YouTube and it appears as though the
left is already bigger than the right on
YouTube and and I know that it can be
difficult because our personal awareness
of different channels might make us
think I can that's called the
availability bias I can think of more
left-wing channels or I can think of
more right-wing channels or I feel like
the right-wing channels I'm aware of our
bigger so the right or left must be
doing better but my understanding is
that actually the left is doing okay on
YouTube yeah um and my second question
or follow up um what do you think the
rate the future repercussions of the
right on YouTube what do you think is
gonna happen to the platform if they
suddenly start appearing left and right
and left and right do you think
YouTube's just gonna keep getting more
political as time goes on or are they
gonna crack down on it what would be the
basis to crack down though I mean if
people aren't violating Terms of Service
and they're generating ad revenue for
YouTube I don't know why they would
crack down on political content oh well
you know because YouTube probably would
sort of see how toxic the discussions
are getting and they would start
cracking down on channels now you do I
mean listen comments or engagement likes
and dislikes are engagement
YouTube wants to make money if if news
and politics is no longer profitable
like if their advertisers say we don't
want to advertise on news in politics
then you might see a crackdown but
otherwise I don't that it wouldn't
happen for the reasons you're saying
fair enough um well I've been watching
your content for love just want to say
you keep doing what you're doing thank
you appreciate the call appreciate the
support great great to hear from you and
a bomber Fox sends a super chat asking
about the recent Supreme Court decision
if it's the one about civil asset
forfeiture we covered it on the bonus
show today so yes I did see that and and
that is a very very good decision okay
that is it for me I know that I have a
lot of people holding but unfortunately
I've got to run I'm making dinner
tonight and it's a it's a whole scene so
I've got to go thanks to everybody who
called in don't troll the live chat
alright don't troll the live chat have
your pets spayed or neutered and I will
stream again very very soon